I think quite often the language we give
about our past it colours are present in
a way so even words like what wanted
Owen say in the previous question I
co-parent amicably with my ex I don't
call my former spouse my ex-wife
I call her my former spouse because
ex-wife has a particular connotation
with it right and I think the same is
true with what wretched alien is saying
here with the they scrutinize my pass
and then [ __ ] about it okay I don't
know what that means exactly they [ __ ]
about it but maybe maybe they're
complaining about it that's the softer
word to use and and then Reggie Allen
says I have a pass it is not glorious
okay it's not glorious but maybe the
lessons from the past are glorious the
whole novel that I wrote was sort of
about that it was about ruminating in
the past and trying to cling to it but
we were talking about the meditation
thing earlier clinging to the past is
impossible we can only keep drudging up
the memories from the past just the same
way you can't cling to that car horn
that just went by it is gone you can't
keep hearing it unless you recorded it
and that's what our memories are in a
way that's like having a recording of
these these past experiences and
replaying it the problem with the
memories are we replay it in a way that
isn't the actual way that it transpired
you